this video is sponsored by skillshare at
the time I'm recording this Colleen
Hoover is one of the most successful
writers in the United States she's
amassed a huge following on Tick Tock
where her books constantly Trend and
have blown up since 2020. Colleen why
are you doing this to me I don't know
I'm sorry the reason I wanted to read
this is because I find this phenomenon
similar to what was going on with a
little life a lot of people like to
record their reactions crying to those
books the reviews of this book are
generally extremely positive or
extremely negative now I went into this
expecting to not like it this is a story
of Lillian Ryle how they fall in love
and what happens to their relationship I
mean the guy is a neurosurgeon who's
also a bad boy it almost turns against
the romance genre it seems like because
we're presented with very typical
romance characters and then we see the
flip side of it when it turns out to be
an abusive relationship we are forced to
reckon with what we have previously read
and we're forced to deal with the
consequences this book is primarily
focused on the theme of domestic abuse
so why is this book so popular Point
number one it's very easy to read I
don't want to look down on that I think
that it appeals to General audiences
because it is General it's also hindered
by that because it's dealing with such a
heavy Topic in order to address this
issue it has to be very didactic and
there's not a ton of nuance there very
rarely do the sentences fixate on
specific details you know we're in
Boston but it doesn't feel like Boston
it could be any City the types of cars
like types of drinks the names of roads
like e-tails are lost it makes it very
readable and delivers an impactful blunt
message but there's not much there
beyond that didactic message so for
those of you who want my unfiltered
thoughts I'll go into spoilers at the
end of the video because I do feel like
I need to rant
a little bit but first a word for my
sponsor skillshare skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes for creators
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost in creativity with
skillshare I love skillshare it's great
I enjoy just like browsing their classes
and trying new things out obviously I've
talked in the past about the writer's
tool kit six steps to a successful
writing habit by Simon van boyem and
that was just a great practical way to
set up a good writing habit which I'm
still working on I'm also trying to
start merch for the channel so I also
looked into graphic design Basics core
principles for visual design by Ellen
Lupton it's curated specifically for
learning meaning there are no ads
they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused
skillshare now offers classes in Spanish
French Portuguese and German the first
thousand people to click on the link in
the description get skillshare for free
for one month go check it out back to
the video I actually like this book I
don't like the writing and I don't like
the characters but I liked it uh just
just get an idea of the kind of writing
style you're dealing with with this book
just here's a few excerpts his eyes
narrow as his hand moves to the
underneath of my foot he slowly traces
his fingers from the tops of my toes
down to my heel I still very much want
to [ __ ] you someone gasps and it isn't
me Ryle and I both look at the doorway
and Alyssa is standing there wide-eyed
her mouth is oh that's her sis his
sister by the way he's just saying this
like with his family around
all right reading about the things my
dad used to do to my mom kind of puts me
in a bad mood reading about Atlas kind
of puts me in a sad mood believe me Lily
I know that wasn't a Pity [ __ ] I was
there he walked out the door and his
words knocked me straight back into my
seat only my seat is no longer there
it's still on the other side of my
office and I'm now on the floor
she forgot that she walked across the
office so she landed on her but the
characters themselves are just walking
cliches the main character's best friend
just walks in to her flower shop and is
just suddenly her best friend you know
snap at the finger insane plot
conveniences to get characters to meet
but again it's more about just like
putting you in to experience the story
as if it's happening to you but I think
the issues that people have with it is
that it can't it doesn't know how it
doesn't have the ability to dive deeper
into the issues of domestic abuse it has
an effective plot structure it's very
well structured in that structure it
loses a lot of character it loses a lot
of Personality there are benefits to
that and there are cons to that some of
my problems with the lack of detail is
that when there is very uh specific
detail on one thing it kind of consumes
the book for example there's no
references to pop culture pretty much
anywhere in the book maybe a few here
and there I think they mentioned Gordon
Ramsay but the one main pop culture
reference this book has is Ellen
DeGeneres extended sequence of this book
where the framing device for the main
character's Journal is that she's
writing letters to Ellen so it starts at
dear Ellen blah blah blah blah blah blah
I didn't mind this I thought it was kind
of like cute okay she's in high school
whatever she likes Ellen but the problem
is as it's like the only pop culture
reference it feels like it's all
consuming it feels like like it's out of
nowhere like why this like weirdly
specific thing all of a sudden if the
book had been populated with that kind
of personality the whole way through
then I think it could have worked this
book is really powerful because it begs
you to interact with its theme some
would call this style manipulative
um Point number three it's manipulative
this book in particular becomes sort of
a morality tale I think it creates a
really interesting conversation
especially around consent and abuse
there are a lot of red flag I mean this
could be called red flag the book uh you
you read it and you go wow this is
really weird Behavior rile basically
stalks her begs for sex repeatedly
ignores her when she says no yet it all
fits within the trappings of romance
novels and romance structure that rile
is abusive could be really shocking if
this were written in a different way
maybe by a better writer this could be
shown in a really effective way to
display how abuse is manifested in small
things and how it escalates over time
and I think that one of the major
failings of this book is that it treats
ryle's abuse like Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde
now Arial the abusive character who on
multiple occasions physically assaults
his partner the main character justifies
his actions by saying that he loses
control that he doesn't have control and
thus he should be pitied for that it
appears as if in the text we support
this narrative that it is as simple as a
switch that goes on and off and not a
pattern of behavior that exists all
throughout everything he does you know
it's not just an on off switch of Dr
Jekyll Mr Hyde I think that framing
benefits the abuser by removing
responsibility from his actions so a
more complex writing style could have
analyzed that however the book itself is
extremely didactic I mean the last line
of the book is the title of the book
it's a message it's a message book
unfortunately the book is bogged down by
its own writing it's just limited by
what it is and what it can be and I
think that Colleen Hoover as a writer
just maybe isn't able to fill the book
as full as it as it wants to be there
are some really powerful statements in
this book though and again it's didactic
and very clear-cut but they are powerful
and and they're really effective I wish
cutting my feelings off for the person
who hurt me was as easy as I used to
think it would be preventing your heart
from forgiving someone you love is
actually a hell of a lot harder than
simply forgiving them I'm a statistic
now the things I've thought about women
like me are now what others would think
of me if they knew my current situation
I'm happy I read the book and if you
want to read it then don't watch this
next part of the video because I wanted
to I want to just rant a little bit of
okay so thanks for watching bye bye bye
okay all right now it's time I died I'm
dead Colleen uh this book is part wish
fulfillment fantasy part nightmare Lily
blossom bloom I don't love that name but
you know they're self-aware at least
right so that first scene with Ryle and
Lily I thought is she is she okay like
this guy is very off-putting I mean the
first scene we see of him he's beating
up a chair on a roof like what is it
what is that about and then he just like
escalates things in such a cringy way it
almost feels like how like a 16 year old
thinks it would be cool to like hit on
somebody like and it's just not it's
just creepy but I mean it seems to work
for Lily so something that really bugged
me is Alyssa uh Lily's best friend and
ryle's sister is really not a good
person okay first off I hate how she
just happens to show up on the day
Billy's there and just be like hey can I
work for you I'm super rich and I just
like doing work and then they become
best friends instantly just like she
falls in love instantly it's just it's
very contrived and very like oh right
this is like high school writing a
little bit I mean obviously it has a
certain polish to it so it doesn't feel
totally high school but it's like okay
give me a break like I get it you just
want to have the best friend character
here and it opens up the ability for you
know rile to come back into her life
anyways whatever the fact that the
second time rail hits Lily I believe he
pushes her down the stairs
Ryle goes to talk to Alyssa and we see
them talking and Alyssa is like
understanding of him or something and
she's like Hawks to Lily and is like
look you have every reason to leave him
but just hear him out first then rile
explains to Lily how when he was a kid
he accidentally shot his brother
in the head with a firearm
so he's been in therapy since then and
has like rage that he like he like he
just like goes into a blind rage like
how does Alyssa think this is
justification for him throwing Lily down
a flight of stairs like
how is she supposed to be a good friend
what was that about like why that's not
good like the third time he attacks Lily
Alyssa's like finally on Lily's side was
like that second time was like and then
it's just like accepted and it seems
almost in the text of the book it's like
okay we accept this like he has issues
you know but the problem is is that the
book frames his abuse as like a Dr
Jekyll Mr Hyde thing it's just on off
and it seems almost like I'm I'm
ambivalent I don't know completely if
Colleen Hoover is aware of all the like
abusive tactics that he made leading up
to it and all of the red flags he showed
or if like Lily she thinks that it's
just an on off thing where it's just
he's just been great the whole time and
then all of a sudden he's bad I mean the
scene at the party when he just like
grabs her and takes her to the room and
she's clearly not happy about it and
everyone just watches as he locks her in
his bedroom is anyone okay with this
they're just letting
it seems weird it seems messed up and
then when she says no she doesn't want
to have sex with him he locks the door
and makes her sleep with him in the bed
not to mention all the whole you know
running down you know knocking on 29
doors to try to find her and then
begging for sex I mean again tastes this
isn't the book you know clear this isn't
the type of genre I'm into and you know
if some people are into that that kind
of romance I don't know like if you're
into that as a as a a courting strategy
so be it but I think that those were
clearly signs that he was heading down
the wrong path not to mention the dick
way he was just like so dismissive of
relationships and of of other human
beings in general obviously there's also
the element of everyone's like a
successful millionaire that's another
thing that a little life did where it
just felt like everyone is you know
suffering from their success or they're
just so successful they don't have to
worry about money and like these other
real practical things that would make it
complex and bring the reader away from
this kind of like wish fulfillment
fantasy of everything going right but
then there's this one wrong thing it's
like it's a it makes it almost
Shakespearean in a way where it's like
we're dealing with kings and queens of
modern world you know you're successful
they're happy but they have these big
problems weighing down on them and we
get to experience suffering through them
in a kind of like this pure lens because
they don't have to worry about money or
other stuff you know exercise it's
interesting fiction exercise I would be
willing to read another Colleen Hoover
book but I you know it's I like the
conversation around it I mean clearly
it's gotten me worked up you know where
I can talk about like you know what was
wrong here what did Ryle do wrong here
and then of course Atlas is I was
interested in Atlas and rile's
relationship I thought the way that was
weaved into the narrative was very good
it was very good except for the Ellen
obviously thing which didn't date very
well but what can you do but having that
interspersed in the narrative was nice
we get some flashbacks I didn't think it
was too cheesy or or ham fisted that was
pretty well done I thought it would have
been more interesting if Atlas was just
a waiter you know but they had to like
make him also a successful business
owner Chef because you know whatever and
then of course she has to be with him at
the end which I thought you know was it
was predictable that she would but it
was necessary like and I also think like
I don't think he saved her from the
relationship I I think that that that
that that Lily saved herself overall the
majority of the book it is cringy
writing it's not super unique and it's
very Bland but again I think the
blandness adds to what makes it work I
think I think that's part of the effect
I'm on to you Colleen Hoover anyways let
me know what you think of it ends with
us have a nice day bye bye foreign
[Music]